quel honneur quel honneur
[Musique]
Eric je partage avec toi ce César cette
musique tu l'avais en tête bien avant de
faire appel à moi
cette ce film c'est un marathon et en
composant la BO j'ai eu l'impression
d'avoir de vivre exactement la même
urgence que le personnage de Julie si
brillamment interprété par l'or je suis
fière d'avoir participé au succès de ce
film mais je voudrais saluer le travail
de toute l'équipe qui a travaillé dessus
je remercie Raphaël Deloche et Nicolas
sans faute de nouveau prod de m'avoir
fait confiance sur ce projet si
ambitieux ainsi que Thibault deboisne à
la supervision musicale et Boris vers
chez mon manager à mes côtés depuis tant
d'années
je salue également mes autres
partenaires but de musique ou arthroom
record Sing Sing bijou production je
pense à mon équipe de tournée qui
m'accompagne toute l'année sur la route
et je pense également à mes parents qui
m'ont toujours soutenu quoi que je fasse
depuis toute petite et bien sûr
j'embrasse Gilles de Givry mon
partenaire de Seine mon partenaire de
vie et qui présente ce soir je voudrais
finir avec une chose ne mettez pas la
musique maintenant ça fait 48 ans que
les 16 heures du cinéma existent depuis
ces longues années 5 femmes ont
précédemment été nommées mais jamais
aucune d'entre elles n'a été récompensée
alors ce César je le dédie
[Applaudissements]